why him a very funny movie and in this
film
your daughter has fallen in love with a
tech sort of tech guru Meyer my daughter
played by Zoe Deutsch the apple of my
eye I'm a Midwestern guy with family
values and she goes out to Stanford
University I'm so proud of her and the
first scene is where her lover starts to
disrobe during a Skype telephone call
and we see some naughty bits yeah you do
see my bare ass yes so that is your that
is go go see it for that reason he
actually passed I know how to hi Pammy
at water when I say that it doesn't hide
my ass no if you go to the 7-eleven on
Riverside you might see my ass
[Laughter]
so not thrilled not thrilled about this
and then you you meet a will you meet
this guy we go out to California he
lives in the Palo Alto area he's a tech
guru kind of guy
billionaire and we meet Laird and Laird
is from another planet mm-hmm he has
tats all over or as my character says he
has twos all over his yeah oh yeah and
he curses up a blue streak he's just not
the image of who I want my daughter to
be with yeah and I hate him I just and
he loves me and wants to be in the
family a tactile James has a lot of fun
getting in real close and yeah you
getting in your space so much so yeah
but yeah and and if we can't we can't
get out of each other's way ya know and
so a lot of comedy hijinks prevails and
it's really really fun we have a clip I
believe this is where you and your wife
played by the amazing Megan Mullally are
together in your room and I think this
is where Laird comes in to have a little
chat yes I believe it and I think he's
just out of the shower possibly the
Cyclops hi I thought you'd be Stephanie
Steph serve a poop we had a big fight
because of the way I behaved at dinner
don't worry we took a shower together
and worked it out but I snuck out to
have a little check-in okay well
Ned would you would you come join us he
wasn't wearing anything under there not
wearing anything under that he wasn't
wearing anything he was he was mr.
commando sometimes that that part of
that robe wasn't in a strategic place
huama here and floppin Hagen and I are
friends and Megan did tell me that she
she saw she she thinks she saw a tall I
don't know how she saw it all but she
must've been looking pretty closely
isn't it yeah it's gonna say he was just
out of the shower that shrinkage yeah
you